demain le ministre des sports monsieur
guy drut a lancé une nouvelle série
d'expériences pour tenter de changer en
france les rythmes scolaires sans
nouveaux sites ont été choisis notamment
dans les banlieues difficiles
il s'agit d'alterner travail le matin et
activités d'éveil l'après-midi exemple
l'école primaire d'evry en ile de france
chantal kimmerlin à la poigne 12h30 la
classe est fini pour la vente les crises
et les cahiers dans les cartes à lui il
est temps de passer à autre chose pour
l'après midi sur bastia de la natation
sport collectif et baseball fait nommer
la musique la piscine irritable la flûte
à bec lycée matériel scientifique
enfin c'est normal et du hockey aussi 15
activités chaque après-midi au choix de
chacun des sports et de la culture
tout ce qu'on n'a pas la maison
forcément une école comme celle là
s'appelait sam des foules femme propose
le soir et le match peut mais travailler
ici on l'a compris il ya quatre ans pour
se battre contre l'échec scolaire la
violence l'absentéisme au mieux encadrer
les enfants l'école primaire devaient
revoir sa leçon de pédagogie
traditionnelle et s'adapter le pari est
gagné nous avons des enfants qui se
déplace dans le quartier sans s'en créer
de perturbations dans le calme qui
peuvent assister à un spectacle sans se
faire remarquer et tous les intervenants
qui travaillent avec nos enfants le
constate une seule école modèle sur les
cinq que compte ce quartier difficile
des bruits c'est peu mais c'est le sait
les formes que je permettre la mairie
l'expérience coûte cher parent fin à
l'école tu es jusque de l'autre côté
c'est 4300 francs à peu près
ici l'enfant coûte 6300 francs trop 6300
et 7000 francs selon lui les années
devenir site pilote apportera de
nouvelles subventions et on espère aussi
de nouveaux espaces ce serait un rêve
que de faire du hockey sur gazon conte
sur glace et non plus sur du goudron